[موسيقى]
اسمك اسمك سعيد
السوداء حول قصه اشهر عمليات في بدايه
الالفينات في السعوديه لما قام احد رجال
الاعمال بتشكيل شبكه من المحتالين عشان
يجمع الاموال من المساهمين ويوزع ارباح
خياليه وهميه عليهم ليصل عدد ضحاياهم الى
اكثر من 40,000 شخص قيمتها مليار و400
مليون ريال سعودي حيث تم الايقاع به لاحقا
ومحاكمتها الفيلم من اخراج عبد الله
القرشي وكتابتها ثاني كعدور وعمر ويشارك
ببطولته وفهد القحطاني خالد يسلم اسماعيل
حسن خليفه همم
تجربه كانت اماره كبيره وتقيله همم لان
اهدافها كانت جدا عالي نطلع نبغى نطلع
بعمل السعودي مشرف ونرفع من مستوى الصناعه
الافلام في السعوديه
لانه الفلوس زي ما احنا عارفين تغير
النفوس فحامد هتغير على فاطمه ام العيال
وما بحرق الباقي وشوف ايش حيصير في
النهايه في اشياء تصفيه حسابات شخصيه
كثير فيها
صراحه في عندي مشهد كل ما يشوفوه البنات
ايوه ايوه
ما راح اقدر احرق اكثر من كده ان شاء الله
اسم الفيلم
الاسم طلع فاكثر من قناه بس كان اصلا طول
الوقت الاسم اسم مؤقت يعني مارسينا كثير
على الاسم
المفروض
هي الفكره الاساسيه الفكره المساهمات
الوهميه وهذه في اكثر من حدثتهم اشارها
اللي همم اللي يتكلم عنها ولكن لا لا حد
يتفرجوا اليوم الفيلم هو شويه بعيد عن هذا
احنا بنتكلم على فكره الشخصيه اللي من رجل
بسيط
في ثلاثه سنين عمل مليار ريال
ايه اللي حصل مره يهمك اجابه يبحث الناس
عندها من زمان هل هيلاقوا هذه الاجابه في
الفيلم لا او لا وهي على موضوع هالقدره
يسترد الناس فلوسهم وفي الاخير او ما
تتطرقوا له
بالنسبه للناس لا بس في بالنسبه فين راحت
الفلوس
مفاجاه لطيفه يعني
[موسيقى]
من الحميه دقه العبيد مع بدا عرضه من ايام
شملت عناصر الابهار والاخراج المثقل
والاهتمام بادقه التفاصيل اللي جاءت
متوافقه تماما مع زمن العمل كما وصفته
الصحافه والجمهور وتناول المسلسل قصص خمسه
اشخاص تعرض قصه كل واحد فيهم في ثلاث
حلقات وعلى الرغم من اختلاف القصص الخمسه
الا انه في رابط ما بينهم راح تكتشفوا
خلال متابعه العمل وتدور الاحداث خلال 20
في اماكن مختلفه كله هند وافريقيا واوروبا
الشرقيه والجزيره العربيه
من النجوم تسهل الى نحو 200 ممثل وممثله
من اكثر من 8:00
و14 موقع طبيعي
اما ازياء العمل واللي تعكس ثقافات
المناطق اللي تنتمي اليها الشخصيات في تلك
الحقبه فقط فوق عددها الاربعاء 700
معها خصيصا للمسلسل هم على صعيد المشاهد
اللي جرى تصوي في البحر فقد تم بناء اكثر
من 35 ديكور داخلي وخارجي ضخم خاص بالعمل
رقم اربع موانئ بالاضافه لبناء 5 سفن
الضخمه على الطراز اللي يعكس المرحله
واحداث العمل
ان العبيد لانجاص منافيله
[موسيقى]
ده الولد اللي بعتلي هو مريض بكم هذا
الولد 60 استرليني
ولا اخذت اربعه حسبتهم لك ب 200
على بيان الفنانه اليسا بفسخ التعاقد
معاهم على خلفيه الاشكالات والحقوق
الملكيه الخاصه باغنيه انا وبس اللي رجع
غناها زياد برجي ببيان مضاد بداتم تمني
انه لو كانت اليسا ومحاميها احتكامول
للقضاء فعلا وليس قولا بهذا الشان وضحوا
كمان انه اليسا صرحت على مسؤوليتها
المنفرده ملكيتها للحقوق الحصريه على
الاغنيه واللي سلمت فعلا للشركه نسخه منها
لي طاحتها وفقا للعقل ما بينهم واتبين
فيما بعد انه نزال ما بين الفنانه اليسا
ومؤلفين الاغنيه المذكوره فالتزمت الشركه
الحياه مؤكده خطيا اليسا بانه لا دخل لها
بالنزاع القائم وانها راح تحدد موقفها منه
على ضوء الحكم القضائي النهائي والمبره
والذي يتم ابلاغها به رسميا اليسا لهذه
اللحظه لم تقوم بالرد على هذا البيان في
المقابل
[موسيقى]